en este vídeo aplicaremos la teoría de
eseverri por sus siglas en inglés
también conocida como tr
ep efe para moléculas con 6 nubes de
electrones entonces nuestro objetivo es
encontrar la geometría del hexafluoruro
de azufre primero vamos a dibujar
nuestra estructura de puntos de lewis el
azufre se encuentra en el grupo 6 de la
tabla periódica así que tiene 6
electrones de valencia por otro lado el
flúor tiene 7 electrones de valencia y
como tenemos 6 átomos de flúor 7 por 6
es igual a 42 y 42 más 6 nos da 48
electrones de valencia en total que
debemos tomar en cuenta para dibujar la
estructura entonces dibujemos el azufre
en el centro que está rodeado de 6
átomos de flúor
vamos a escribirlos
tenemos 6 átomos de flúor alrededor de
nuestro azufre ahora vamos a contar el
número de electrones que ya dibujamos
aquí tenemos 2 4 6 8 10 y 12
entonces 48 menos 12 nos faltan 36
electrones por colocar y los podemos
poner en nuestros átomos terminales los
átomos de flúor recordemos que el flúor
sigue la regla del octeto y como cada
flúor ya tiene 2 electrones a su
alrededor
simplemente colocamos 6 electrones en
cada flor
por 6 es igual a 36
hemos colocado nuestros electrones de
valencia y esta es nuestra estructura
ahora vamos con el segundo paso que es
contar el número de nubes electrónicas
alrededor del átomo central entonces
necesitamos identificar las regiones que
tengan densidad electrónica como este
enlace y este todos estos enlaces son
regiones de densidad electrónica que
rodean a nuestro átomo central se
consideran nubes electrónicas la teoría
de spr dice que todos estos electrones
de valencia están cargados negativamente
y por lo tanto se repelen entre sí
tratan de estar lo más lejos posible
entre ellos entonces cuando tenemos seis
nubes electrónicas se forma algo muy
parecido a un octaedro
para estar lo más alejadas posible
trataré de dibujarlo tiene ocho caras en
este caso tenemos al azufre en el centro
y luego tenemos un punto justo arriba
que se conecta con las esquinas de la
figura central ahí está y lo mismo
ocurre con un punto abajo también lo
conectamos con la figura central
entonces este es un octaedro en donde
cada uno de los vértices representa un
átomo de flúor
este es un átomo de flúor aquí tenemos
otro y en total tenemos 6 átomos de
flúor en nuestro octaedro y esto
corresponde al paso 3 la geometría que
forman las nubes electrónicas que se
encuentran alrededor del átomo central
es octaedro finalmente el paso 4 es
ignorar cualquier par de electrones
libres en el átomo central para
predecir la geometría final de la
molécula entonces como no tenemos
electrones libres en el átomo de azufre
la geometría de la molécula es igual a
la geometría de las nubes electrónicas
por lo tanto la geometría de el
hexafluoruro de azufre es octa every k
octaedro pero analicemos un poco más
nuestra molécula en términos del ángulo
de enlace si partimos de este flúor de
arriba hacia el flúor que tenemos abajo
podemos ver que uno de los ángulos de
enlace en nuestro octaedro es de 180
grados y también tenemos un ángulo de 90
grados porque si este eje que acabamos
de dibujar se une con este flúor aquí
tenemos 90 grados y desde otras
perspectivas también se encontrarán con
ángulos de 90 grados por ejemplo aquí
tenemos otro ángulo de 90 grados y aquí
tenemos otro así que en una geometría
octaedro y acá tenemos 6 átomos de flúor
que ocupan 6 posiciones que son
equivalentes y eso facilita las cosas
muy bien ahora veamos el penta fluoruro
de bromo
efe 5 sabemos que el bromo tiene 7
electrones de valencia y el flúor
también se encuentra en el grupo 7 pero
como tenemos 5 átomos de flúor 7 por 5
es igual a 35 y 35 más 7 nos da 42
electrones de valencia y entonces
pongamos al bromo en el centro y está
unido a 5 átomos de flúor
muy bien hasta ahora ya representamos 2
4 6 8 10 electrones de valencia entonces
42 menos 10 nos faltan 32 electrones por
colocar que podemos empezar poniéndolos
en nuestros átomos terminales los átomos
de flúor
entonces para que el flúor tenga su
octeto le faltan 6 electrones agreguemos
6 electrones a cada átomo de flor
entonces al agregar 6 electrones a cada
uno de los 5 átomos 6 por 5 es igual a
30 y 30 menos 32 nos faltan 2 electrones
por colocar recuerden que después de
colocar los electrones de valencia en
los átomos terminales si aún quedan
electrones debemos colocarlos en el
átomo central así que tenemos un par de
electrones libres en él
regresemos para recordar los pasos
después de dibujar la estructura hay que
contar el número de nubes electrónicas
alrededor del átomo central para después
predecir la geometría entonces veamos
cuántas nubes electrónicas tenemos
alrededor de nuestro brom
aquí tenemos esta región de densidad
electrónica también tenemos este par de
electrones que forman otro enlace al
igual que este también este y este
tenemos cinco nubes electrónicas pero
recuerden que este par de electrones
libres también es una región de densidad
electrónica así que en total tenemos
seis nubes electrónicas y como vimos en
el ejemplo anterior al tener seis nubes
electrónicas la geometría es de tipo o
cta erika y bueno como todas las
posiciones del octaedro son iguales no
importa en donde pongan
el par de electrones libres y entonces
este es el bromo y voy a poner un átomo
de flúor por aquí y otro por acá otro
hacia adelante y otro hacia atrás
después pondré uno hacia arriba y
finalmente pondré el par de electrones
libres hacia abajo es más fácil porque
para predecir la geometría de la
molécula debemos ignorar cualquier parte
electrones libres en el átomo central
entonces si ignoramos este par de
electrones libres voy a conectar los
átomos de flúor aquí tenemos una base
cuadrada y cuando la conectamos al flúor
que tenemos arriba nos queda una
pirámide tenemos una pirámide de base
cuadrada la geometría es pirámide
cuadrada
pirámide cuadrada
y en términos de ángulo de enlace
sabemos que tenemos ángulos de 90 grados
justo como en el ejemplo anterior
tenemos ángulos de 90 grados en la
geometría de pirámide cuadrada hagamos
otro ejemplo de seis nubes electrónicas
ahora tenemos detrás fluoruro de xenon
primero calculemos los electrones de
valencia el xenón se encuentra en el
grupo 8 entonces tiene 8 electrones de
valencia y el flúor está en el grupo 7
pero como tenemos cuatro átomos de flúor
7 por 4 es igual a 28 y 28 más 8 nos da
36 electrones de valencia entonces
dibujemos el xenón en el centro
y está unido a cuatro átomos de flúor
ahí está ya tenemos 2 468 electrones de
valencia entonces 36 menos 8 es igual a
28 electrones que nos falta colocar y
podemos empezar en nuestros átomos
terminales los átomos de flúor
cada flúor quiere tener su objeto y a
cada uno le faltan seis electrones de
valencia entonces colocamos 6 electrones
de valencia en 4 átomos de flúor
por 4 es igual a 24 menos los 28 que nos
faltaban aún nos quedan 4 electrones por
colocar y los pondremos en nuestro átomo
central tenemos dos pares de electrones
libres en el xenón
regresemos para recordar lo que sigue
después de dibujar la estructura hay que
contar el número de nubes electrónicas
para predecir la geometría de esas nubes
entonces contemos cuántas nubes
electrónicas tenemos recuerde estamos
buscando regiones de densidad
electrónica este enlace es una nube
electrónica al igual que este enlace
también éste
ahora en este ejemplo tenemos dos pares
de electrones libres que también se
consideran regiones de densidad
electrónica así que tenemos seis nubes
electrónicas en total y ya sabemos que
cuando hay seis nubes electrónicas
quieren estar lo más lejos posible y
tienden a formar un arreglo o cta
hedrick o entonces si los pares de
electrones libres quieren estar lo más
lejos posible del otro vamos a ponerlos
a 180 grados están lo más alejados
posible ahora pongamos los átomos de
flúor aquí tenemos uno por acá tenemos
otro y tenemos otros dos
ahora si queremos saber la geometría de
la molécula de tetra fluoruro de xenón
debemos ignorar los pares de electrones
libres en el átomo central observen que
en este caso tenemos algo parecido a un
cuadrado dibujado en el mismo plano así
que la geometría se conoce como cuadrada
plana
esta es una geometría cuadrada plana y
los ángulos en esta geometría son de 90
grados entonces así es como podemos
predecir la geometría de moléculas que
tienen seis nubes electrónicas el primer
ejemplo no tenía pares de electrones
libres alrededor del átomo central el
segundo ejemplo tenía un par de
electrones libres y el tercer ejemplo
tiene dos pares de electrones libres
pero aún cuando las nubes electrónicas
tienen la misma geometría la geometría
de las moléculas cambia porque no se
toman
a los pares de electrones libres en el
átomo central